so there was good news last night there
was I don't want to be one of these
conservatives who is just constantly
catastrophizing everything and saying
that the sky is falling down there was
good news JD Vance beats Tim Ryan in
Ohio an important senate senate seat
this race had been kind of close uh JD
Vance is a new right kind of candidate
he's a candidate who's running not just
on the old tired you know tax cuts and
ignore the culture kind of issues but JD
Vance is running unexplicitly a
pro-family policy he's running on an
anti-immigration platform not just
anti-legal immigration but restricting
all immigration so he's running a very
conservative
kind of trumpy kind of populist kind of
nationalist kind of whatever IST you
want to call it not the old Rhino
establishment kind of campaign and that
was a big win because Tim Ryan the
Democrat had positioned himself as a as
a working man's Democrat you know I'm
not one of these latte sipping liberals
I'm uh I'm a blue-collar kind of
democrat and it was completely
disingenuous coming from Tim Ryan but
the pitch seemed to be kind of working
on the campaign Trail okay JD wins in
Ohio they say as goes Ohio so goes the
nation so that was good stuff
uh bad news we just got out of Michigan
uh Whitmer this awful leftist governor
in Michigan she beat Tudor Dixon who had
made a real play for Michigan uh good
seemed like a decent Republican
candidate but just could not go the
distance so Democrats win their uh Kathy
hokel in New York beats lizelden the
Republican I don't want to beat up on
Lee zeldin too much Lee zeldon ran a New
York Republican kind of campaign he's
not some rock ribbed right-wing
conservative but he put up the most
credible
campaign the most credible threat to
Democrat power in New York since George
Pataki it was a really impressive
campaign he got pretty close he lost in
the end Kathy hokel wins the Democrats
win
too bad uh The Big Race that people are
looking at is Herschel Walker versus
Raphael Warnock right now that is in a
complete Dead Heat neither candidate as
of some minutes before this show began
today neither candidate had over 50
percent which means that that race is
likely headed to a runoff it's a little
frustrating too
because the libertarian candidate there
did act as a spoiler and even just the
one to two percent that the libertarian
candidate got would be enough to have
put Herschel Walker over the line but
Herschel Walker had problems as a
candidate so it could be headed to a
runoff if that race goes to a runoff
probably doesn't bode very well for
Herschel Walker because Herschel Walker
was riding I think he hoped National
political headwinds for the Republicans
and was riding on Governor Kemp's
coattails uh Governor Brian Kemp won so
that's an important race uh but for
Herschel if it's just him just versus
Warnock knowing also that Democrats are
much better at runoff type races that's
not great news
now I mentioned Brian Kemp this was
fabulous news so Brian Kemp absolutely
destroys
the
Governor Pretender in Exile uh Stacy
Abrams the president of the universe
according to Star Trek Stacey Abrams has
never really conceded her gubernatorial
loss in 2018 and she just got completely
destroyed with facts and logic and votes
last night it was so bad that she had to
concede this is a woman who a lot of us
thought maybe she just won't concede she
still hasn't conceded her race from four
years ago well she had to concede this
time it was just so bad he beat her 53.5
percent to 45.8 percent so you can't
really claim voter fraud in that in that
kind of a race especially when the
Democrat loses and the Democrats are the
ones who are known for their Shenanigans
so she lost and she she's conceded and
then another totally satisfying race
this was so delicious this was so
delectable
Beto O'Rourke just got
btfode I mean just got absolutely blown
out of the water and uh the race was
55.6 to 43.1 percent uh devastating
Republicans are just being absolutely
merciless in their mockery of him which
we will get to a little bit later on in
the show but but really really good news
there uh and then there were just some
some losses and one of the most painful
losses for a lot of people I think is
the Pennsylvania Senate race Dr Oz loses
to John fetterman here's fetterman's
victory speech
yeah I uh I'm I'm not really sure really
what to say right now my goodness
[Applause]
I am
yeah
[Applause]
I mean uh
foreign
[Music]
I'm so humbled thank you so much really
thank you thank you
John fetterman I am not really sure what
to say right now truer words have never
been spoken by a Victorious Senate
candidate now this one did not surprise
me this surprised a lot of Republicans
didn't surprise me I was predicting
fetterman would win going into the
election uh that's because well one it's
because Philadelphia is known for some
Shenanigans especially in close races
but even more than that because Dr Oz
was a terrible candidate and I've made
no bones about that fact I think he's
just awful I think he's a total loser
and so I'm not surprised that he lost
uh and it was it was unfortunate that he
was the nominee and then he lost to a
man who had an absolutely horrible
record no professional accomplishments
in his life a radical vision for the
country and brain damage such that he
couldn't even really campaign
nevertheless he won and that's a real
gut punch for Republicans now again I
don't think the fact that Republicans
lost to a guy with brain damage as is
the headline right now I don't think
that's actually the big issue here
okay because if it were me if I were a
Pennsylvania voter and it were reversed
and it was the Republican who had had
some health problem and he wasn't really
functioning he wasn't on the campaign
Trail versus some articulate Democrat I
would still vote for the Republican I
don't really care I want the Senate
majority I want a guy who's going to
reliably vote for the right stuff and so
I I'm not really surprised by all that
the health issue it doesn't doesn't bug
me nearly as much as his just insane
policy agenda now I mentioned this
question of Fraud and irregularities and
shenanigans and all of that I don't
think Republicans can blame these losses
on voter fraud because we did get most
of the results last night relatively
quickly now you might still say there's
a big problem with widespread mail-in
voting I do think that's a problem I do
think that's open to abuse I do think
there's a problem with ballot harvesting
I do think there's a problem with early
voting I think all of these things are
absolutely awful and have no place in a
a stable sacred democracy that we are
supposed to be and I do think it opens
up the possibility of fraud that's not
my crazy conspiratorial view that's the
view of Barack Obama That's the view of
basically everybody with two brain cells
to rub together so
yeah that's all a problem but we did get
most of the results last night
and so there are other problems there
are other political problems why did the
Republicans not do nearly as well as we
were supposed to
we'll get into that the rest of the show
continues now it is woke Wednesday we've
got an ad from fetterman that my
producers tell me is one that I actually
didn't play I haven't seen this one so I
guess they just want to rub salt in the
wounds of Senator fetterman coming out
uh you don't want to miss this part of
the show
if you're not a member click on the link
in the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]